parce que nombreux 54 53 54
c'est comme ça que les graves et deux
dans les yeux que s'il fait ça comprend
50 passes étaient nourris sur
l'importante à proto sortait en couloir
pendant sur un contact céline numéro de
notre champagne 51 jamais là tu es ont
préparé combien tu vas pas recommencer
avec les parias qu allons nous tourner
la pièce les règlements de compte je
dirais c'est là bas salaires bas chez
beaucoup la comaga autres par téléphonie
c'est la revue de faction fils s'est
soumis les choses utiles pour perpétuer
les goûts ah non c'est pas ça que ça
marche comme ça
je t'aime s'était enflammé faut du temps
la police va temps pour vous en parler
parler d'eux mêmes dans l'ambiance
quel grand